bandai namco is well known for
publishing hardcore action RPGs like
Dark Souls so you probably have an idea
of what they're tackling next it's a
free-to-play PC golf game called winning
putt what was that not what you were
picturing winning putt comes from Korean
developer webs no net it's a pretty
grounded Dolph simulator though you can
level up your golfer to hit with more
power or even curve the ball in midair
and of course there's plenty of gear
like clubs gloves and shoes to unlock
you can even spend money to enchant your
clubs with special abilities winning
putt is slated to have seven 18-hole
courses when it launches that's on top
of a country club that serves as a hub
world full of NPCs and players you'll be
able to form their own golf guilds there
too webzine hasn't revealed a release
date but winning putt is launching an
open beta today january fourteenth you
can head to gamespot for our full
preview and for all your sports game
news you'll already be in the right
place